I started analyzing paintings as a way
to confront the problem of not engaging
with certain forms in genres of art you
stand at a museum look at a Kandinsky or
a Monet or Seurat and wonder what
exactly am I supposed to feel here
certain paintings seem particularly
stubborn unwilling to move even an inch
in your direction leaving you with a
massive void to fill with unanchored
interpretation but what about paintings
that do the opposite Rene Magritte's the
treachery of images moves more than an
inch in the direction of the viewer it
goes all the way the painting speaks in
a language that we can understand which
is to say language itself so seeing
opossum peep this is not a pipe the
painting actually says something it
engages it talks so what's it trying to
say first let's talk for a moment about
Rene Magritte one of the most famous and
lasting of the surrealist artists a man
who never really thought of himself as a
painter more a thinker that used images
to express himself once he landed on an
aesthetic style that never really
changed or evolved throughout his career
well versed in philosophical writing
from Plato to Foucault he used that
style to investigate ideas his program
was to confuse to evoke mystery to show
us that what we want is always behind
the thing we see and that the
obstruction can never be removed
completely because it's not in the
object its envisioned and thought itself
the treachery of images approaches these
themes directly the painting at first is
obvious in its message it shows an image
of a pipe and then underneath the image
it tells or reminds the viewer that this
is not a pipe and we can infer the rest
obviously that's not a pipe it's a
representation of a pipe and Magritte
means to show us that representations
are not the real thing they only
resemble the real thing but of course
that's common sense who in the world
would argue the opposite position but a
curious question comes out of this if
someone showed you the
Civic and asked you what it was what
would you say probably you'd say it's an
apple right or what about this image
it's a man or this this is a train this
is a house this is a dog this is a hand
this is a pipe this little accident of
language is not really an accident at
all for many hundreds of years human
beings have supposed that language and
reality had an organic relationship that
the names of things in a way arose out
of the things themselves that a tree was
in fact a tree that Kanye West is in
fact Kanye West and that a pipe is
really a pipe all of that was challenged
by the famous linguist Ferdinand de
Saussure an extremely influential figure
who saw that a thing and its name have a
totally arbitrary relationship that we
don't really know things but only access
their shadow through language in which
everything has a meaning in the context
of the system after so many centuries of
trusting the word implicitly these
insights were hard-won so hard one that
Magritte saw that the old wrongheaded
ways of thinking about language were
still hiding in the way we thought and
talked about images realistic painting
plays on resemblance and resemblance
suggests a hierarchy that the image of a
pipe resembles that it points outside
language to the thing in itself the
falseness of this claim is what inspired
the abstract artists to move beyond
resemblance into a field in which
painting had no reference in reality as
such Magritte on the other hand makes
this point using the false premises of
resemblance and shatters them from
within the visual secret dependence on
language is laid bare in the treachery
of images indeed that dependence is the
treachery of images here we have an
image and a sentence laid out like a
page from a botanical textbook begging
to be connected but why should we
connect them why should the sentence and
the image refer to one another how do we
know that the word this points upward of
course we don't know but the pronoun the
resemblance and the name
all make that connection inevitable and
it's that inevitability that's made real
in every aspect of our lives we go about
our days confident that everything we
see could be set and that the images we
say could be seen but if you've ever
used the phrase you had to be there you
know that these are two realities that
do not overlap in the way we act like
they do this is not a pipe yes but this
is not a pipe either and if this is not
a pipe then the sentence scrawled in its
cute schoolboy cursive is actually a
contradiction a contradiction that pulls
the whole painting apart at the seams
and makes it uh der nonsense I don't
know if Magritte laughed about that but
I hope he did because what's more
forceful not moving an inch in the
direction of the viewer or moving a
question all the way into the center of
the viewers mind that on the slightest
prodding and examination implodes
hey everybody thanks for watching boy
that was that was really fun to do I
wanted to let you know that there are
only five nerdwriter mugs left on my
patreon page so if you want to claim one
of the last few click anywhere here on
the mug or in the description also a lot
of people on the last video commented
who didn't live in the u.s. saying they
might also be interested in a mug so if
you are let me know in the comments
below so that I can gauge interest and
maybe we can do a whole separate batch
for you guys thank you so much for
supporting me on patreon guys really it
is I say this again and again but it is
what makes this channel possible they
wouldn't exist the nerdwriter would not
exist without your help and I am trying
to build it up a little by little it you
know it's it's a model for supporting
content that I really believe in I mean
you pay to get the content that you want
there's nothing in between you and me
it's just me and you it's a beautiful
bright it's my birthday and it actually
will be my birthday yesterday but it's a
beautiful birthday gift from you guys
and I will see you guys next Wednesday